here's the most important question
people ask me this question all the time
they say Steve what is your favorite
ever episode on the DI ofo podcast and I
think the more important question is
actually what is your favorite episode
on the Diary of AO podcast of all time
and so I went out to try and answer that
question what is your favorite episode
what is your favorite moment on this
podcast of all time and using a data
scientist and a big team of analysts
we've found the most replayed moments of
all the hundreds of episodes we've
produced this year to show to you today
these are the moments that you replayed
and shared more than any other moment on
this podcast
theoretically this should be the most
valuable D CEO episode you ever listen
to because it's a compilation of the
most valuable moments that we've ever
had on this show in 2020
[Music]
three the seventh most replayed moment
is my conversation with jles yo where he
takes on some of the biggest myths about
Health weight obesity and he answers the
question do we have to get fatter as we
age is it genetic what are the easy ways
to manage our weight after I read it in
your book about us gaining more and more
weight we age I Googled it and the
healthcare research and quality agency
said that we naturally tend to gain
weight as we age to the tune of 1 to two
pounds per year according to their
review and that's from the agency for
healthare research and quality which I
found quite startling but completely
accurate so the numbers so what what the
numbers that we have is yeah I think
that's right actually so between 20 and
50 years old those 30 years intervening
the average person average will gain
about 15 kilos in weight which is 32.
yes 2 pound a year 1 to 2 pound a year
15 kilos in weight is gained over 30
years on average some gain very little
others gain a hell of a lot more we look
at ourselves in a mirror I look at
myself in a mirror um but it's true I
don't want to be that guy mate I don't
know how much choice you have what can I
do to to to try and stay cuz for me it's
not really about the weight thing or how
you look it's more about like
I I am I don't know how to say this but
there was this big set of stairs the
other day really really long set of
stairs leading down to this Lake I was
in Indonesia a couple of months ago um
and I I remember thinking about those
stairs and thinking God if I wasn't you
know athletic and strong and didn't have
good knees and things like that there's
no way I'd be able to get down this long
winding handcarved set of Indonesian
stairs so that I could go on this boat
trip that I was going to go on and I
just thought about how it was a weird
thing I know this is kind of a strange
story to tell but it crossed my mind I
got to the bottom of the stairs and I
turned to the person I was with and was
literally like you know that's why I've
got to stay in shape for as long as I
can because I want to do these boat
trips and I want to go on this little
rafting thing but I won't even be able
to access it unless I can go down up and
down those stairs like 200 meters of
stairs down this Cliff um so that's what
I care about I care about being active
and strong and fit for as long as I
possibly can and I from what you've said
about gravity and weight um being
overweight is going to inhibit my
chances of being able to do those stairs
so so that I think there are two
elements there first of all there is
doing the things that we want to do okay
like that because you're exactly right
these are the things which I can still
do that I can still walk up a mountain
or down a mountain because I'm still fit
enough to do that and I want to stay as
fit as long as I can to do that and
weight will inhibit that undoubtedly but
then there's a second element to
actually consider now there Healthy Look
none of us are going to live longer we
hopefully and anyway if we let lived
longer but was unhealthy would you want
to live longer so you want to live
longer but healthier for longer okay and
undoubtedly the thing that is closest
related to health when you age is not
your total weight there's a role to play
there the amount of muscle you have it
is your muscle mass as you age
independent of how much fat you have
okay that will determine how healthy you
are as you age so as so now the M now
I'm talking about going into the 60s and
the 70s rather than when one is able to
go down a 200 met set of steps okay so
now as you get older the most crucial
bit of information is to maintain
resistance training not lifting and
that's not what I'm talking about
sitting on a wall getting up and down a
chair because that the amount of muscle
mass you have really really really marks
the level of Health that that you're
going to get and then the the science is
startling it is so so so related of
independent of independent of weight you
know from from from from there so muscle
mass is the most important for healthy
aging the moment you get 60 70 plus
interesting okay so I'll keep I'll keep
doing resistance training correct always
keep resistance training and lifting
weights as long as I can lifting weights
as long as you can at some point you
won't be able to lift
weights don't don't write me off don't
write me off John the hubis of Youth
yeah that's the naivity of Youth yeah
you just assume you'll always be able to
do what you can do now I I yeah it's
something I think a lot about and I
think a lot of people will watch this
podcast
because probably especially this time of
year we're in January they'll probably
be trying to find ways that they can cut
fat they want to be a bit skinnier you
said think you said half a stone you
want to lose I'm in the same place I
think most people want to lose a half a
stone or something what is the way that
you would suggest to do that the simple
way you know not the like
complicated go by this guy's course and
do three million sit-ups whatever the
simple advice you would give someone
that's H hoping to create sort of
sustainable weight loss so the first is
the amount of protein you eat and you
need to try and focus on trying to keep
to about 16% of the energy in your day
okay from protein 16% and there's a
sweet spot so if you eat too much and
you're not lifting you're stressing your
kidneys because your kidneys have to get
rid of the nitrogen from the protein
okay so 16% is a sweet spot and it
doesn't mean steaks only it can mean
beans tofu any kind of protein from from
anywhere 16 % second is fiber we need to
eat as much fiber as physically possible
okay 30 gr we want to aim for although
we are looking at the moment on average
in this country we're probably only
eating 15 grams we need to double the
amount of fiber we actually eat third we
need to limit the amount of added sugars
into our diet added sugars meaning
sugars not tied up in fiber powdered
stuff uh uh um maple syrup alav nectar
all those are added sugar SE put in keep
it to 5% or less of the of the energy
content in your day and those are the
three numbers that that that I want you
to think about so 16% of protein 30 gram
of fiber 5% or less of added sugars
apply that to whatever you want what
keto um whatever you want to do apply
that and I think that will be a
sustainable healthy way to eat the sixth
most replayed moment is a conversation I
had with Dr Mindy pels who talks about
the belly F burning diet nutrition is a
huge thing at this time of year and so
she lays out exactly how to eat and
behave in order to reduce belly fat and
to improve your overall health you told
me about the first two styles of fasting
the first one was intim fasting which is
12 to 16 hours which is good for weight
loss brain fog that kind of thing the
second is autography autophagy what did
I say autography but I like it I said
autophagy I said autophagy we can play
that back I definitely said autophagy
and if I didn't we'll fix it with AI um
autophagy fasting which is 17 to 72
hours good for balancing sex hormones
and preventing illness yeah number three
we haven't spoken about gut reset fast
yeah what's that yeah so that's based
off uh a study that came out of MIT that
showed 24 hours without food and your
intestinal stem cells inside your gut
actually start to reboot themselves now
a stem cell is a cell that can go to
anywhere in the body and repair itself
but at 24 hours you get a plethora of
them in your gut and in the gut we've
got a damaged microbiome from everything
that we've just been talking about so
what I discovered in this 24-hour fast
is I could take women that have been on
birth control pill for years um people
that had been on multiple rounds of
antibiotics people who had been eating
horrible food and I could actually put
them through a 24-hour fast once a week
once once every couple of weeks and
these stem cells would come in there and
they would start to repair and so now if
I teach that person How to Eat Right
their food is actually starting to build
a better microbiome in the gut so that
24-hour fast became this go-to in my
clinic where I could take all these gut
challenges and I could start to unwind
them just because I knew the body had
this capability of making these
intestinal stem cells and it was crazy
like we got people off supplements we
got people that were didn't weren't
making serotonin which affects moods
comes from the gut all of a sudden start
to become happier people who hadn't had
bowel movements in like three days all
of a sudden we started to put in these
this gut reset and it was like a miracle
it was incredible number four fat burner
fast so the fat burner fast is probably
my favorite for those people who want to
lose weight the research was done that
36 hours without food followed by 12
hours of eating and then another 30 they
actually did it over a 30-day period but
we've been using it in our community
just dosing it in that at 36 hours what
happens is that's enough time where the
blood sugars come come down where all of
a sudden the body it's so smart it goes
okay blood sugar is not common we've
been in this fasted State we've
triggered autophagy we've brought
inflammation down we've made you ketones
we're trying to go find food but this
extra weight not serving you you because
remember you got to go find food so it
drops weight and it's the most beautiful
way to get a person to unstick any kind
of weight loss resistance but most
importantly you know where it dropped
the most amount of weight from where
does everybody want to lose weight belly
yep so it is the I probably should have
called it the fat burning belly fat
burning the belly fat yeah that would
have banged yeah but yeah and so that's
what they showed is that actually a 30
36 hour fast started to unstick weight
loss and it was started with weight
around the
belly
compelling number five the dopamine
reset fast yeah so number five um I
found some research showing that when
people go without food for 48 hours the
whole dopamine system will be rebooted
so what's important to know about the
dopamine system is it is our molecule of
happiness it is the thing that it's
actually a motivation molecule and it's
a neurotransmitter that allows thoughts
happy thoughts to go across from neuron
to neuron and so what happens and I'm
sure you've talked about this on your
podcast that we're so dopamine saturated
right now but specifically people who
are Overeaters they actually are finding
the study I quote in the book is that
they found that people who had food
addiction people who had extra weight
like obese
situations they were not getting as much
happiness out of their food because
their dopamine receptor sites were
saturated so they had to eat more food
to get more happiness and a lot and you
know food is a state changer it does
make us happy so what they found is if
they put them into a 48 hour fast that
they actually rebooted the whole
dopamine system and new dopamine
receptor sites appeared so that when
they brought food back into the equation
they actually got more enjoyment out of
food with less food this kind of got me
thinking about a conversation I was
having yesterday with some of my team
here we were talking about how um it
almost feels like sometimes if I've
eaten sugar I can go into a bit of a
sugar cycle and what I mean by that is
I'll have some sugar and then like a
couple of hours later I'll have another
craving for sugar and then a couple of
hours later I'll have another craving
for sugar but then at other times
specifically for example when I did keto
I was I did the keto diet for about
eight months uh8 weeks bloody eight
months I wish um eight weeks and
throughout that period I didn't have any
cravings for sugar yep I would we had
some chocolate come into the studio and
I walked over to the chocolate and I
smell it yep and I didn't want any of it
y it had gone but then when I'm in my
what I call like the sugar cycle I'm
eating sugar maybe you know once or
twice a day and I'm getting like the
craving for it where which I just can't
seem to resist yep well dopamine's the
molecule of more it's not the molecule
of enough so what it does is when you
get sugar you get this dopamine rush and
the Brain goes woo love that give me
more of that and so you con you it's
it's endless you will never be fully
satisfied it constantly wants you to
come back for more and more and more so
when you start to go off the ketogenic
Energy System you're getting the same
Euphoria you probably felt the same high
the same mental Clarity but you've
totally taken this molecule more out of
the out of the picture it's it in fact
dopamine will actually you know you you
get those receptor sites that will be
repaired but you're not getting a big
dopamine buzz when you're in a ketogenic
state you're getting ketones I was I was
mulling it with my team how long I had
to stay away from sugar to kind of get
out of that vicious give me more cycle
yeah my experience has been it's about
three days three days that's what I
thought yeah I think I said four or five
but it's just from experience as well if
I haven't had sugar for three or four
days I mean like a like a chocolate but
something significant in terms of sugar
then after 3 or 4 days the craving for
it seems to to vanish yeah yeah it's not
it's not if you think about that it's
not hard if you're trying to overcome a
sugar addiction yeah like just bear it
for three days and then that dopamine
stops barking at you and then if you
attack fasting onto it now you're
getting ketones and so you're not
needing that as much ketones kill hunger
and they make you so mentally mentally
clear they give you this euphoric
feeling so you don't have that urge to
go for the for the sugar and the ketones
come from fasting which is when your
body switches metabolic State yeah the
last and final
fasting style immune reset fost yeah so
immune reset was built off of Dr wter
Longo's work and he did a study on
people who had cancer and were going
through chemotherapy and one of the
challenges we know about chemotherapy is
that it wipes out the whole immune
system and so he wanted to see well what
if I put somebody in a fasted State as
they went through chemotherapy would
there be a difference and what he found
is after 3 days of fasting the white
blood cells in our system actually
reboot themselves so what they do is all
old white blood cells are are slued away
and new white blood cells emerge so
people were able to come out of that
chemotherapy experience and have a
stronger immune system as opposed to
what we were seeing was that it was
wiping the immune system out so that
launched the whole three-day water fast
sort of craze at least here in America
we're seeing a lot of people that are
just going after 3-day water fast to
Prime their immune system but you also
also at three days get stem cells full
systemic stem cells so all of a sudden
your body's got in surging with stem
cells going to all parts of the body
repairing it the great example I always
use on this one was I had an Achilles
tendon injury and nothing was nothing
was helping it so I threw a 5day water
fast at it on the fourth day I felt this
buzz in my achilles tendon and I was
like oh wonder what that is is and it
stayed all the way through I went five
full days and um about the fifth and
sixth day so sixth day I was entering
food back in all the pain completely
went away and it never came back I tried
everything I tried everything and that
was the only thing that repaired
it it does make again evolutionary sense
that if our body senses we're injured
because we're not eating or you know
some other signal that we
are
on a course to not survive to put it
nicely it does make sense that it might
set about to repair whatever needs to be
repaired you're getting it you know cuz
like if I was a wounded human back in on
the savanas of I don't know Africa or
wherever we came from um and I'm laid
there and I'm not eating my body should
probably go okay Steve might need
something fixed so that he can get back
to yeah hunting so you're getting it so
survival that is the number one priority
of the body so when you go without food
you amplify every resource it has to
keep you alive and if repairing my
achilles means I can now go hunt for
food it's going to do that it's going to
make me stronger and I in the book I I
stumbled when I was writing the book I
stumbled upon a really cool hypothesis
that's called the Thrifty Gene
hypothesis and it said that what it's a
theory obviously it's hypothesis it's a
theory that the people the humans that
evolved out of the Primal days had a
very specific genotype and this genotype
allowed us to metabolically flex and and
be stronger in a fasted State because we
had to survive and the people that
didn't make it from that time period
didn't have that Gene but think about
this for this moment so they think we
all have this Gene inside of us right
now this Thrifty Gene where we can go
long periods without food and we can
survive so what happens when we're
eating all day what happens when we're
ignoring and we're not actually
activating that genetic profile so what
they are now believing is that diabetes
metabolic syndrome all of that is
largely happening because we are going
against the G the genetic profile that
we are now seeing in humans we're like
on the opposite end of the spectrum
we're overloading our bodies yeah
which is meaning that the survival Gene
you reference there is not being
activated to help us that's right that's
right interesting the fifth most
replayed moment is a moment from my
conversation with Matthew Walker who is
the world's number one expert on the
subject of sleep he explains the
importance of sleep on our overall
health on our weights and everything in
between but most importantly of all he
gives us a road map for how to sleep
better and I know so many of you are
struggling so I'm not surprised that
this is one of the most replayed moments
of the dire of a CEO of 2023 had a lot
of Health experts on this podcast
recently but none of them have really
talked to me about the role that sleep
or sleep deprivation plays
in
wait is there a relationship it's
probably one of the most well defined
relationships that we know in all of
sleep
science and it is at least a three-part
story so the first emerging evidence
came in terms of um hormones so there
are what we call appetite regulating
hormones and the two principal ones of
concern here are something called leptin
and grin now leptin when it's released
will signal to your brain that you're
satisfied with your food you are
satiated and you are no longer hungry
grin does the opposite when grin is
released it says no you're not satisfied
with your food you are not full you
still want to eat more you are still
hungry and some of the first the they
started to just limit people restrict
people's sleep to 6 hours or 5 hours or
4 hours and what they found was that um
there
was firstly that signal leptin that says
no you're satisfied with your food you
don't want to eat anymore you're full
that signal of fullness satiation was
decreased by 18%
if that wasn't bad enough grin which is
the hunger hormone that laed up by
28% overall hunger levels Rose by about
uh
26% so firstly you are it's almost like
double jeopardy that you are getting
punished twice for the same crime of not
sleeping enough once by losing the
signal of I'm full I I don't want to eat
anymore and once again for the no I'm
much more hungry and I'm just going to
overeat which is
grin so what that produces is a profile
of increased eating so on average
underslept individuals started to eat in
those studies about 3 to
400 extra calories at each sit at each
sitting by way of insufficient
sleep then what they discovered is that
it's not just that you want to eat more
it's what it is that you have a craving
for when you are
underslept and this is the problem what
they found is that when you underslept
you eat more of everything but you
especially eat more of these
heavy-hitting stodgy carbohydrates bread
pasta
pizza the the next thing that you
started to eat have a preference for was
simple sugary Foods sweets and chocolate
and then finally you started to Crave
very salty food and high sodium food
intake will increase your blood
pressure so that was the first of the
the three mechanisms then we did a study
where we said perhaps it's not just the
circulating hormones in the body the
brain is the ultimate Arbiter of your
food decisions so what's going on in the
brain so we took a group of perfectly
healthy individuals and we put them
through the experiment twice once when
they'd had a full eight hours of sleep
and once when we deprived them of sleep
and then the next day we place them
inside an MRI scanner and we showed them
images of lots of different foods that
range from being sort of you know very
healthy to being very unhealthy and S of
ice cream and you know chocolate and
pizza and things to Leafy salads and
nuts and greens and vegetables and we
asked them to rate how much they wanted
that food for each item now we did
something a bit sort of dedly to make it
more ecologically correct so that they
weren't just saying okay they probably
think I should probably say that's
healthy we said we're going to randomly
select one of these images these food
images that you see and after you get
out the brain scanner we're going to
give you that food and we're going to
politely ask you to eat it all so it
made it a bit more realistic so the
choices were more you know as much as
that we could so what we found is that
when they were sleep deprived the Deep
honic centers the emotional centers of
the brain these desire centers these
reward centers um they ramped up in
their activ ity in response to these
highly desirable highly unhealthy Foods
so these more basic sort of you know
gutteral parts of the brain as it were
um these reward centers were lighting up
much more strongly when you were sleep
deprived were still the impulse control
regions in the front of the brain what
we call the prefrontal cortex they were
shut down they were taken offline so as
a consequence you lost your impulse
control and that's why you start to then
say you know when I'm sleep rived at the
food sort of buffet I'm not not going to
do salad I'm just going to that pizza
looks awful good or that Pastor with the
cre I'm just going to go into that all
go so so your it's what we call a
pattern in terms of brain activity uh in
Neuroscience of honic eating that your
brain goes into this honic desire
profile so now we understood it's not
just hormones in the body it's also
changes in the brain then came the
finding that there's another chemical in
the body that's
responsible and this comes on to
cannabis when people
um when people when people that you may
know have smoked cannabis they'll often
say I get viciously hungry I get the
munchies I get really hungry that's no
coincidence because cannabis will
stimulate appetite now we all have
naturally occurring cannabis compounds
in our brain and our bodies they are
called endoc canabo Endo meaning comes
from inside us um whereas the Cannabis
that comes externally when you sort of
smoke it or um take
Edibles
so endoc canabo do many things for the
brain and the body but one of the things
that they do is control your appetite
and your hunger and what we found is
that when you sleep deprived individuals
these naturally occurring endoc canabo
rocketed up by over over
20% cranking up people's
appetite and so these three ways lead
you to start packing on you know when
insufficient sleep is occurring when
sleep gets short your waistline
typically starts to expand and we Now
understand the reasons if that wasn't
bad enough it is bad enough the yeah you
just stop M honestly I really uh the the
last thing that we discovered is that
let's say that you're trying to be
really careful and you're trying to diet
and you're trying to lose
weight if you're not getting sufficient
sleep then 60% of all of the weight that
you lose will come from lean muscle mass
oh God no and not fat not the muscle I
know exactly so in other words when you
are dieting but you are underslept you
lose what you want to keep which is
muscle and you keep what you want to
lose which is
fat so again it's I'm sold not an ideal
situation sleep is important I get it
I'm sold how do I my question is what
are the things that in the modern
society are standing in the way of sleep
we've touched on some of them Loosely
but some of the like big obvious things
the things that you would suggest doing
very actionable things we could do
straight away to improve our chances of
having that healthy um deep sleep that
we need to be um optimal in every regard
of our health and performance there's
probably I think five standard tips what
we call sort of sleep hygiene that you
can do and then I'll come on to maybe
just some unconventional tips uh that
we've sort of touched on and we've
spoken about many of these the first
thing I would recommend people to do and
this is why when some people say oh what
about this new sleep supplement or you
know it's it's 40 quid for this bottle
of the Sleep new sleep natural
medications so I'm going to give it a
try I would say try these tried and true
things first before you spend your money
on supplements the first thing is
regularity go to bed at the same time
and wake up at the same time no matter
whether it's the weekday or the weekend
your brain expects regularity it thrives
best under conditions of regularity when
you give it regularity you can improve
the quantity and the quantity of your
sleep the second thing is get some
Darkness at night as I said we don't get
enough darkness in the modern world and
so the trick I would offer and I don't
use I don't like the word hack but the
suggestion would be in the last hour
before bed try this experiment for
everyone listening for the next week dim
down half of the lights or switch off
half of the lights or even a 3/4s of the
lights in your home in the last hour
before bed all of the lights in every
room in all of the rooms you know switch
off almost all of the light now I'm not
suggesting be unsafe and walk around in
the darkness in the last hour that's not
what I want to saying just dim down you
know switch off half of the lights you
will be surprised at how sleepy that
Darkness will make you feel and it's
also an incredible behavioral
trigger to signal to your brain that it
is time for sleep that darkness is
around me that's the second tip is
Darkness the third T tip is temperature
most people sleep in an ambient bedroom
temperature that is too high and you
need to aim for a bedroom temperature of
about 18 18 1 12 degre cus around about
65 to 68° fahit if I'm probably
butchering the the mathematics there on
that but um you need to get cool now you
can wear thick socks you can have a hot
water bottle that's fine but the ambient
needs to be cold because you need to
drop your core body temperature and your
brain temperature by by about 1° C to
fall asleep and stay asleep and it's the
reason that you will always find it
easier to fall asleep in a room that's
too cold and too hot so make your
bedroom cold make it dark like a cave
the the fourth question would be sort of
what we've or fourth suggestion would be
Walk It Out and we've spoken about this
the 30 minute rule you know get up do
something different or meditate you know
don't lie in bed awake for too long then
the final two things we've spoken about
well we've spoken about caffeine we
haven't spoken about alcohol but let me
just say as the kind of headline of it
alcohol is not a sleep aid many people
use it as a sleep aid it is not your
friend alcohol again is a sedative so it
knocks you out the second is that it
fragments your sleep so you wake up your
sleep is littered with all of these
small Awakenings most of them you don't
remember because it's too brief but it
makes for miserable lousy quality sleep
and the final thing is that alcohol is
very good at blocking your REM sleep or
your dream sleep which we know is
critical for many other functions as
well so alcohol is not your friend
that's the sort of the final tip again
you know just every if you're with
friends have a glass of red wine just
know okay my sleep's not going to be
great thank
you and you know I'm not yeah
I'm whatever it's just you know live
life too I'm not saying that the fourth
most replayed moment is a moment for my
conversation with the world leading
neuroscientist the man who has scanned
more brains than anybody else Dr Daniel
aiman who is a favorite on the D CEO and
he tells us very very clearly how to
grow a healthier brain I can change my
brain it's the most exciting lesson that
I've learned you're not stuck I'm not
stuck with the brain I had you're not
stuck with the brain you have you can
make it better I can prove it in fact
every day what I've come to believe
you're making your brain better or
you're making it worse let's start there
by what you're doing what things make
the brain worse what are the common
things that most of us do without
thinking that make the brain
worse when my daughter Khloe was in
second grade I went to her classroom and
I wrote 20 things on the board and I
went separate them for me good for your
brain bad for your brain seveny olds
they got 19 out of 20 right so most
people
know the only thing they got wrong was
orange juice they put it in the healthy
category when in fact when is it
rational to unwrap fruit sugar from its
fiber source because it turns toxic in
your body so I'm not a fan of fruit
juice I'm a fan of fruit not fruit juice
what's bad about sugar for the brain
pro-inflammatory
which what does that mean it makes you
diabetic but I mean as it relates to the
brain why is like orange juice or the
ice cream bad for my brain because it's
ultimately going to give you high blood
sugar levels MH which erode your blood
vessels and you're going to have lower
blood flow to your brain that that's a
bad thing I mean there's so many things
about it so it's addictive it's
pro-inflammatory it makes it more likely
you're going to have diabetes and
obesity so 72% of Americans are
overweight 42% are
obese I've published three studies on
35,000 people as your weight goes up the
actual physical size and function of
your brain goes down that should scare
the fat off anyone I used to be chubby
but when I figured out that connection
I'm like oh no I'm it was that that gave
me the motivation to drop about 25
pounds and so
sugar is the gateway drug to diabetes
and obesity and so not to
mention
inflammation which is the cause of
depression and dementia so you want to
avoid things that cause low blood flow
caffeine nicotine caffeine caffeine
constricts blood flow to the brain what
does that do to my brain Con well
constricts blood flow so you're going to
get less blood flow and remember I
showed you that progression with
age no you don't want that you want to
do things that increase blood flow to
your brain so exercise genko it's this
one of the supplements I'm going to give
you eat foods like um beets
oregano Rosemary cinnamon they increase
blood flow while we're on blood flow 40%
of 40y olds have erectile
dysfunction 70% of 70y olds have
erectile dysfunction what that means if
you have blood flow problems anywhere it
means they're
everywhere and
so like
No And it means either you're too
sedentary you're overweight you're
smoking or having too much
caffeine or using marijuana because
marijuana lowers blood flow to the brain
and so just in that one of the
11 it's
exercise
genko for you not for everybody but for
you hyperbaric oxygen those three things
will make a big difference difference in
blood flow genko genko what is that it's
a supplement what does it do uh
increases blood flow to the brain the
prettiest brains I've ever seen take
genko there's actually a spec study uh
they gave uh people
120 milligrams of genko twice a day
significant Improvement in blood flow to
the
brain and so in one of the supplements
I'm going to give you we have genko I
I've taken it every day for the last 20
years at least and then this is where
the US government got an F for the
pandemic loneliness accelerates dementia
and brain problems and so when they
isolated us the whole significant
increase in brain problems so get
connected to other people the i in
bright Minds is inflammation so what
increases inflammation low omega-3 fatty
acid levels and we are
deficient 93% of the population is
deficient in omega-3 fatty acids
93% so all of us should be either eating
more fish
or taking an omega-3 supplement like
fish oil gum disease like who knew like
I wasn't really that good at taking care
of my gums until I started reading the
study
you have gum disease you have
inflammation you're more likely to get
depressed and have dementia the third
most replayed moment is a moment from my
conversation with Gary Breer where he
lays out how you can become a superhuman
strip the fat off your body and get
yourself healthy with free easy simple
exercises that will cost you nothing at
all when I heard the story about Dana
White and I saw he had gone from
respectfully being a man that had a
little bit of weight to to having this
these sixpack abs on Instagram of course
the sixpack isn't the the outcome it's
as you've said it's the stuff going on
inside him that's really the
transformation but what can someone
who's just heard that at home where do
they start with getting extending their
life by triple and getting the so you
know he also started something called
the Superhuman protocol and superhuman
protocol is using magnetism oxygen and
light right so the only things that we
really get from Mother Nature the the
the big benefit we get from mother
nature is we get magnetism from the
earth we get oxygen from the air we get
light from the sun the truth is most of
us are not contacting the surface of the
Earth that much anymore so he bought
$150,000 worth of equipment a pmf mat an
oxygen what's called a hypermax oxygen
to do exercise with oxygen therapy and a
red light therapy bed and I had him use
that equipment every single day seven
days a week but if your listeners want
to do it for
free you can take off your shoes and
contact the surface of the Earth and I'm
talking about bare feet on soil dirt
grass sand because earthing and
grounding is a very real thing we
actually discharge into the Earth we
actually human beings build up a charge
do you know that pH the acid alkaline
scale pH stands for potential hydrogen
it's a charge it's a complete fallacy
that you can get alkaline by drinking
alkaline water that's the biggest
marketing myth ever sold to the public
um but you can get alkaline by
contacting the surface of the Earth so
if you don't have 150 Grand which I
don't expect anybody listening to this
podcast to spend 150 Grand but he did I
said you need a MAG you need a pmf mat
so you can be alkaline you need to spend
10 minutes a day breathing um 95% O2
under mild exercise and you need to lay
in a red light therapy bed so in the
absence of the Superhuman protocol you
can become superhuman by contacting the
Earth and by learning to do breathwork
let's talk about breath work I spend
eight minutes every day doing a very
specific series of breath work people do
not realize the power of something that
is so accessible so free and so easy to
do right they they want things to be
more complicated but it's not and when I
said the presence of oxygen is the
absence of disease it's absolutely true
remember that every elevated emotional
state that a human being can experience
actually has in its molecular structure
oxygen is a component of that emotion so
if you look at the difference between
passion Elation Joy arousal libido and
anger for example it's usually only one
neurotransmitter and the presence of
oxygen the reason why no human being is
ever woken up laughing is because you
don't have the oxidative state to
experience laughter right out of deep
sleep but can you wake up angry yes
because anger doesn't require oxygen so
every morning contact the surface of the
Earth and then spend eight minutes doing
I do a wimh off style of breath work I
give credit where credits do he's the
father of breath work as far as I'm
concerned so I do three rounds of 30
deep breaths
like obnoxiously deep breaths and I
start by trying to take my belly button
and pull my belly button out towards the
wall imagine there's a string pulling
your belly button towards the wall and
then you you fill from the loes of the
lung to the apex of the lung and then
you exhale and just
relax did God knows what they think
we're doing out there right outside this
gu they're like a bunch of freaka I knew
it was a cult um KN I knew he was a cult
leader but um so you do three rounds of
30 breaths on the 30th breath you exhale
and you hold allow the carbohydrate rep
receptor to reset when you don't feel
you can hold anymore you take a deep
breath in you hold again and you let it
out
slow and you start again I would suggest
that you start with three rounds of five
breaths then work to 10 15 20 25 and 30
if you get lightheaded this is a good
sign that the oxygen tension is changing
in your brain if your fingers and toes
get tingly this is a good sign that
you're changing the oxygen tension if
you feel some kind of heat uh
temperature change in your neck these
are all Great Signs you will get to the
point where you can actually hold your
breath for two or three minutes
sometimes four minutes between rounds of
breath work um and then the last thing
is to expose yourself to natural
sunlight first thing in the morning the
first 45 minutes of the day God gives us
a very very special type of light called
First Light there's no UVA there's no
UVB rays in this light um so that it's
not the damaging Rays from the Sun it
still generates vitamin D3 it has a
positive effect on cortisol on vitamin
D3 first light is the best way to reset
your circadian rhythm so by contacting
the surface of the Earth doing breath
work and getting first light you can get
to the same place that Dana White did
with 150 Grand in equipment what about
oxygen masks cuz I I'll be honest when I
read when I read um about the Dana story
I went on Amazon soon after and I was
like like I'm just going to buy an
oxygen canister good idea bad idea um so
what you want to do is um you know you
get an oxygen concentrator which takes
21% oxygen from which is what the
concentration at sea level it turns it
into 95% O2 and it fills this bag and it
can refill this bag over and over and
over again okay I use one called the
hypermax you can see it on my Instagram
and um you turn you plug it in you turn
it on it fills this bag and then you go
in you put an oxygen mask on and you
exercise for 10 minutes only 10 minutes
cycle for 3 minutes uh Sprint for 30
seconds cycle for 3 minutes Sprint for
30 seconds cycle 3 minutes Sprint 30
seconds and you're done and what this
does is it raises something called the
partial pressure the the storage of
oxygen in your blood the only two time
two-time Noble Ora Prize winner in
Medicine Dr otter warberg won both of
his Nobel prizes for his work in
exercise with oxygen therapy you want to
be a superhuman do mild exercise every
day while breathing 95% O2 it's
important that you're exercising and
then after that you move into a red
light therapy bed
photobiomodulation um so you know if you
don't have access to a hypermax oxygen
machine just do the breath work get the
breath in you know exchange the oxygen
tension and the tissues and expose
yourself to First Light what about cold
cold W of plunging so I'm a huge fan of
cold water plunging but probably not for
the reasons why you think you know um I
also sit on the board of the NFL um uh
Alumni Association athletica as a health
service director you know there there
was a time when we used to think that
putting athletes and cold water after
exercise was good because of its
anti-inflammatory effects we know now
that that's only about 15% of the
benefit the majority of the benefit
comes from something called a cold shock
protein if you really want to be
fascinated Google cold shock proteins
these are reserved proteins that are in
your liver they're dumped into the
bloodstream in effort to save your life
when you put yourself in cold water they
scour the body of free radical oxidation
they increase the rate of protein
synthesis muscle repair they are free
you get them when you put yourself in
cold water um I don't know what the
Celsius conversion is but I use 50° for
3 minutes minimum 6 minutes maximum cold
yes it's it's actually not that cold I
mean you know I see people getting in 37
38 degree water there's no evidence that
I've read that shows that colder is
better you get a peripheral Vaso
constriction so it forces all the oxygen
into the core and up to the brain um and
you you get an activation of something
called Brown fat right um thermogenesis
comes from Brown fat and for the women
that are listening for some reason I
seem to ins snare the women when I say
this remember that the definition of a
calorie is a measure of heat right I
mean the definition of a calorie is the
amount of energy it takes to raise 1
cubic centimeter of water 1° Centigrade
so if if if a calorie is a measure of
heat then this means that when Heat's
leaving your body calories are leaving
your body so if there is nothing nothing
no amount of exercise hits cardio no
type of cardiovascular or weight
training that comes anywhere close to
immersing yourself in cold water in ter
terms of what will strip fat off your
body fast if you want to strip fat off
your body get in cold water 3 to 6
minutes a day that's fascinating because
because the oxygen rushes to my head
that's why it has a really profound
impact on mood that's why it has a very
profound impact on mood because if you
think about it what's the reason why we
need deep sleep what happens in deep
Sleep that's so special there's a
secondary oxygen transfer we transfer
oxygen from the periphery from the
extremities to the brain remember the
brain's a non-metabolic organ so in
other words it's unlike muscle if I pick
up a weight and start to work out my
muscle my arm my body will send more
blood more amino acids more oxygen to
that muscle because it's working well if
I'm sitting at my computer and I'm
watching reruns of The Simpsons or I'm
sitting at my computer and I'm solving
the most complex joint venture agreement
partnership agreement with all kinds of
mathematical equations my brain gets the
same amount of nutrients same amount of
blood flow same amount of oxygen so it
eats the same meal whether or not it's
in a dead Sprint or whether or not it's
just chilling on the couch
except in deep sleep and when you're in
cold water because it's forcing the
oxygen up to the brain the second most
replayed moment is a moment from my
conversation with Dr Tim Spectre a
favorite on the Diary of a CEO and here
he talks about health more holistically
and some of the biggest myths that most
of us believe that are currently
standing in our way we've got a fitness
group amongst some of my friends there's
about 10 of us in it and um
we've been tracking how often we work
out and how frequently work out and the
workouts that we do and one of the
things I have to say is pretty much no
one in the group has lost any weight
we've been doing this for a
year and uh that kind of bucks what you
would think so the only time that I lost
weight was actually when I went on the
keto keto diet I went from 14 Stone 8 to
13 stone8 in roughly in several weeks
but exercise and exercising for almost
religiously for the last 2 and a half
years doesn't really seem to impact my
weight at all in a you know in the way
that the fitness experts might tell me
on Instagram what's your stance on the
role that exercise play plays in weight
loss has very little role in weight loss
all the studies long-term studies show
uh it doesn't help uh weight loss and
it's been grossly exaggerated as an easy
fix for our obesity problem exercise
doesn't help weight loss no all the
studies show that the only caveat to
that is if you have have changed your
diet improved your diet and you've lost
some weight at maintaining some exercise
does help prevent it going back up again
but as on its own if you don't change
your diart it's of no use and that's
well known Now by all the Obesity
experts and all the studies does sugar
makers fat is that the
culprit is that one of the main things
that's contributing to no again that's
that's reductionism you know
the but the reason the reason
exercise doesn't work it's important to
realize this is because we all know this
that you know you go for a walk build up
Hunger before a meal that's what your
parents told you you know and everything
about exercise is after it your body
slows down your your metabolism slows
down and it tries to regain the energy
that you've lost that's just what our EV
Evolution and so that's why it's a
you're not going to it's great for your
health I'm I know I exercise fantastic
for your mood um it's great for your
heart anti-cancer all kinds of things we
should all do it but absolutely not if
your goal is weight loss you have to do
something about changing your diet and I
think that's that's the big a huge myth
particularly pereto by gyms and uh
fitness apps and everything else and it
it is complete nonsense I read that you
um when you looked at studies over 30
years and you looked at how many studies
had been done on the relationship of
exercise and weight versus things like
sugar and weight there was 12 more 12
times more studies done on the
relationship of exercise and weight
versus sugar and weight and why why is
that why is there less research done on
the
latter um I think that's the influence
of governments and the food companies
and the drink companies so uh a lot of
the exercise research done in the last
20 years was sponsored by uh large
corporations who wanted to make this
link between
uh exercise and weight loss so that they
could continue to sell sugary Ultra
processed foods and drinks and just say
it's you know childhood obesi because
we've we don't have playgrounds and we
don't uh encourage this and that's why
the the Cokes and the Pepsis are always
there at the Olympic sponsoring Olympic
events and associating themselves with
Sport and they gave hundreds of millions
to various physiology departments Sports
departments nutrition departments to do
research in this area basically it was
really hard to get anyone to do research
into how sugary drinks make you uh gain
weight or cause problems because they
the amount of money for nutrition has
been abysmally poor you know in from
from governments and that's why you know
we the only the first ever study of
ultra-processed food in a controlled
trial was only about three years ago and
it's been around for you know 30 40
years so such is the power of that Lobby
that it it doesn't necessarily distort
the research in a sort of you know evil
way but they point it to make sure that
the researchers are working in an area
that that they want uh people to work in
and distracting them keeping them away
from talking about sugars or even
artificial sweeters which in my view are
nearly as bad because they're sort of
you know hidden um and deflecting us
from the idea that yes giving kids
sugary drinks or even artificial sweet
drinks is going to be bad for them and
cause obesity wait so I'm I've been I've
cut my I cut out sugary drinks about a
year ago I still have the same Brands
but I have the no sugar version oh dear
oh what do you mean oh dear well
all the all the summary of the trials
shows that if you take uh young adult
young adults and kids and they would say
on two cans of you know full sugar sodas
and you change them to the diet version
there's no real difference in in weight
or um
metabolic um changes in their blood
uh the you will go to the dentist less
so you don't get as many fillings
but and yet you you should be gaining
300 calories right if you doing two cans
a day so it doesn't work out as it
should do and that's because of the
extra these chemicals are not inert so
the sweeteners in kids they change their
their brains to give
them they want more Sweetness in their
food okay so it it could reflect your
wish for your your late night milk
chocolate who knows um and it it makes
it very difficult train kids to have
more bitter Foods or sour Foods if
they've got these artificial sweeteners
in their diet all the time but they've
now shown that all these sweeteners
actually affect your gut microbes so
even Stevia you know these sort of
so-called healthy ones have an effect on
your gut microbes and they're not inert
so we know that saccharin and suc also
cause spikes in your blood sugar uh when
I did it you know have a
trace they not supposed to but they they
actually do things they're not supposed
to so we know very little about these
these products and my view is that they
are harmful probably not as bad as
having the sugar but they are absolutely
not a health drink and we should be
encouraging people to have you know teas
and kombuchas and uh more more bitter
tasting interesting flavors and Foods
than just this Ultra sweet uh chemical
concoctions it's this sugar conglomerate
that have been funding much of the
research that points towards um some of
the things you're talking about
there there that's also the conglomerate
that wants us to believe the calories in
calories out approach because if I just
view every all foods is kind of equal
and on this sort of calorie number then
I can drink some of the sugary fizzer
fizzy drinks and some of the processed
foods as long as I keep it within that
sort of calorie deficit I'll be fine and
so are they is that Sugar conglomerate
is the processed food conglomerate for
the calorie model absolutely they need
that right they absolutely it's vital
you know zero calories or one calorie
you know on the can that's what you see
and you know you're fooling people into
thinking this is a healthy drink and oh
you know if I used to have full Coke or
Pepsi and now having the diet version
I'm getting 300 calories less a day I
should lose weight it's exactly what
they've been doing and they're also
desperate to show that artificial
sweeteners
are really healthy and they come down on
anyone who who tries to say that they're
you know could be any way dangerous and
yet they're not obliged to test them so
none of the none of the chemicals added
really go through rigorous testing on
how they affect our gut microbes and
this is is this you know their testing
mechanisms haven't changed in 50 years
as you'll know if you've listened to
this podcast before I'm an investor in a
company called hu I'm on their board and
they sponsor this podcast and I have a
very exciting announcement to make this
product called Daily Greens is one of
the most highly requested products at hu
but it's never been sold in the UK
before
until now it's often difficult to get
all of the greens into our diet that we
need to have a healthy gut microbiome
and a healthy body and with hu's daily
green product with one scoop every
morning a very very delicious scoop you
can get 91 vitamins minerals and Whole
Food Source nutrients into your diet the
most important Point here is I genuinely
believe it tastes delicious it's May my
favorite heel product ever for all the
reasons I've described so if you want
access to this product you can sign up
right now the link is in the description
below it launches in the UK in January
because of the demand I'm pretty sure
it's going to sell out and here is the
single most replayed moment as a it
relates to Health on the Diary of a CEO
of 2023 so the first thing I came up
against because this was around the time
of the financial crisis was the lack of
understanding of the brain Body
Connection so these high performing
Executives were kind of acting
like their body was just the vehicle
that was moving their brain around from
meeting to meeting and both
disrespecting their their physical
health but also not understanding that
what they were actually really being
paid for was to use their brain and they
weren't creating the best conditions for
that brain to operate in um and I'm
talking about really basic things like
sleep and a good diet and hydration and
not being sedentary managing your stress
Etc so you know this tiny
organ if it's not in an environment that
is giving it the best chance of doing
its job it's not going to and a crack's
going to appear somewhere um
and the first time I really kind of had
a big confrontation with a bank was when
people were dropping dead on the trading
floor of heart attacks and they asked me
to work more in my capacity as a former
medical doctor to help with the physical
stuff and I said I can't do that if we
don't address the mental and emotional
piece because that's what's causing this
and they just could could not get that
what did you want to do with those
people in a specific and practical sense
what if you could have you know been in
charge of preventing them from dropping
dead on the trading floor where would
you have started the understanding that
stress so everything that you're
experiencing mentally and emotionally
that's challenging and things like a lot
of travel which is challenging for your
body that that raises levels of the
hormone cortisol which comes from your
adrenal glands and that cortisol courses
around your blood through your entire
body and brain and the brain has
receptors for understanding what's going
on in terms of threat to your survival
so in a 24-hour cycle depending on your
age and your gender there's a normal
range for cortisol so it can go up and
down like this you know if something
challenging happens we need to adapt and
rise to meet that challenge but when
that level is above the top range all
the time these receptors in your brain
basically think that there's an imminent
threat to your survival so there's this
whole Cascade of hormones and they
basically cortisol causes inflammation
in the body so inflammation of your
vascular system inflammation around your
heart and everything else gut and you
know other things but particularly
around that time we were seeing a lot of
heart attacks caused by stress this was
in the absence of high blood pressure
high cholesterol smoking it was all
stress once upon a time I Googled um CU
I had a thesis I Googled is stress
contagious and it came up and it said it
was
contagious is it contagious in what
circumstances do we need to be aware of
that contagion and more importantly how
and why is it contagious okay I will
tell you the answer to that but I'm
going to ask you a question first have
you ever walked into a room with someone
and by the time you've left that meeting
with them you just feel so
drained okay so course yeah yeah you
know so you know the feeling so I'll
I'll tell you how it works
physiologically um I'm going to start
with something else to like build you up
to this story so did you know that women
who live together or work closely
together will synchronize their
menstrual periods within two or three
months so whenever I want to explain
something that's complex or I don't
actually know the current Neuroscience I
always take it back to what happened in
ancient times so when we were living in
the cave the men hunted and gathered and
lived lived quite nomadically so
sometimes they would go away for months
at a time and in those days the most
fundamental important thing for the
survival of the human species was that
the alpha male must pass on his
genes so if he was going to be away for
months and he couldn't you know that
there weren't men there to defend the
women from predators maybe there was
going to be a spell of the Ice Age and
they would all freeze to death or they
wouldn't have food um he needed to make
sure that at least five women were
impregnated with his sperm at the same
time so that if there was a food
shortage or there was like still birth
or miscarriage or whatever at least one
out of five would survive so to be able
to do that they had to be fertile at the
same time so that's why that mechanism
exists now we don't need that mechanism
now but it's still wired into the way
that we operate so those sex steroid
hormones like estrogen and progesterone
they leak out of our sweat about this
far around us and that's why if you're
living with another woman or if you know
you're sitting across the desk every day
then particles of hormone from my sweat
would go into the through the skin of
the other woman if she's within what
distance I mean it's not you wouldn't
have to be sitting next to each other if
you live together that that means you're
interacting enough that it would happen
Okay so particles but not not if you
work together if you work together and
you sit right next to each other every
day then it does happen too so you know
in a a small office that's got like six
girls in it that that the menstrual
synchronization will happen
interestingly it's led by the alpha
female so yeah so you can you can work
out if you don't know already who the
alpha female well if you you know
basically let's say My Cycles don't
change and everyone says oh I got my
period early or I haven't had my period
yet but now it's started then that would
mean that probably I was the alpha
female how does the body know who who
the alpha female is that will be to do
with levels of testosterone why why did
the body why does that matter who the
alpha female is why does it matter that
they syn up with her I I don't I don't
know if it really matters I think it's
just a case of physiology so it's a
little bit like in the um troops of
gorillas the stress levels of the silver
bat gorilla affect the other gorillas
more than gorillas who are peers to each
other so there is we have a natural
hierarchy and it must be related to
survival as well so she was probably the
person who the alpha male was going to
impregnate first probably so everyone
needs to kind of fall in line cuz when
she starts having sex they need to be
ready yeah okay and also it'll probably
be to do with things like you know
survival genes so it'll be the people
with the hardiest genes because that's
what you'll want to pass on as well okay
makes sense most resilient okay okay so
where were we stress and Contagion all
the hormones in the menstrual cycle so
basically cortisol is a hormone that
works in that same way so cortisol is
the main stress hormone and this one
doesn't matter if you're male or female
but it does matter where you are in the
hierarchy of the organization as I just
mentioned
so usually in that conversation that I
mentioned to you where you go into a
room and you just feel completely
drained afterwards usually the person
that comes out feeling drained is less
senior than the person that's had that
effect on them and that's why this is so
crucial to
leadership because your stress levels as
a leader as a CEO are going to have more
impact on everybody else than the rest
of the people um put together basically
so managing your stress is obviously
important for you but it's important in
terms of what happens to other people
and the first issue I came up against
was CEOs and CFOs that said well I won't
show them that I'm stressed I won't I
won't tell them what's happening with
the numbers I won't display emotions in
front of them and I said they're still
going to know physiologically it's going
to impact them so now you really have to
do something about
it um and the other thing about cortisol
which is quite funny well one of the
side effects is quite funny is that as a
survival mechanism it will help you to
store fat around your
abdomen so you know again in the cave if
you were potentially going to like not
find food for a month then if you had
extra fat around your abdomen you could
digest that and survive till you could
find
food so with my clients in financial
services it got to a point where as soon
as I walked into the room they just lift
their t-shirt up and say now you know
how I've been in the last month so
stress causes belly fat belly fat that's
really hard to shift so again what I
would see with people is that they would
say oh I've put on a bit of weight
around the middle you know had to loosen
the belt a bit so I've started started
eating less I've started like exercising
more and I still can't shift it and
again that's when I would explain this
is the impact of cortisol as long as
you're still leaking out extra cortisol
nothing's going to change
so and like I said even exercising more
or eating better less or differently
whatever it is wouldn't shift that fat
you had to get to the root cause you had
to reduce the cortisol for any of you
that are still here I have a bonus
moment for you I often get asked what is
my favorite episode of the dire of a CEO
of all time and I often try and avoid
that question because I don't want to
pick one particular episode it's kind of
like picking your children however
because you've gotten here I'm going to
reveal it to you and I'm going to play
you a moment from that conversation my
favorite ever episode on the Diary of a
CEO of all time is
episode
1001 and it just so happens to be the
most shared episode we've ever ever had
of all time on WhatsApp and I know that
sounds a little bit obscure but the
interesting thing about WhatsApp is it's
one to one typically so it's typically
one friend sending it to a family member
or to a friend or something like that
and for it to be the most transferred
between one person and another I think
is telling about the value of that
conversation here is one of the most
important moments from my favorite
episode on the Diary of a CEO of all
time
to understand what happiness is you have
to understand the cause of it yes and
you write about that extensively and
solve for happy so what is the cause of
unhappiness as you see it especially if
you're building sort of machine learning
applications that are going to you know
um solve you know make people arrive at
contentment or happiness in a
personalized way we must be able to know
what's causing this lack of allow me a
bit of time to explain it because it
it's simple when we get it but it's not
simple to get to it so so happiness is
very predictable okay if if you look
back at any point in your life where you
ever felt happy there is one commonality
across all of those moments that can
actually be do be documented in a
mathematical equation okay you've never
felt happy because of a specific event
in your life okay uh take for example
rain rain doesn't make you happy or
unhappy there is no inherent value of
happiness in Rain okay rain makes you
happy when you want to water your plants
and it makes you unhappy when you want
to sunbath right and so it it's not just
the event rain it's the comparison
between the event and an expectation in
your mind of how life should be okay if
you're worried about your plants then
life should be generous to me and get me
rain so I can water the plants and if
life does that then life meets your
expectations and you're happy okay and
so happiness in that sense becomes equal
to or greater than so it's really
mathematics the your perception of the
events of your life minus your
expectations of how life should be okay
and apply that to anything apply that to
anything so you know my favorite example
is nature we're all happy in nature why
are we all happy in nature I mean you go
out there and there are ants and there
are flies and you know trees are crooked
and there are you know shrubs everywhere
and bushes and it's just really not that
hedged and organized but that's what we
expect so you know Nature's chaos is
what we expect nature to be and so we
feel happy you know nobody ever sits in
front of the ocean and says I like the
view but please mute the sound okay you
just take it you know it's it's the
monotonous sound and the view and the
wind and and the Sun and the whole
experience right uh and because of
that uh happiness becomes very different
than what was defined to us okay what
was defined to us is that happiness is
found in a a gathering at the pub or a
party or a you know an activity or some
kind of pleasure or fun or Elation or
whatever that is that's not at all true
these I I call these the state of Escape
okay happiness as per the definition of
the happiness equation is events equal
to or beating expectations life going my
way okay and so basically happiness is
that calm and peacefulness you feel when
you're okay with life as it is it
doesn't really matter what life is okay
what matters is that you can be okay
with it right so so you take you know
the any example huh if your boss is
annoying and your expectation is yeah
bosses are annoying this is what life is
about they become bosses because they're
annoying right and and so if if that's
your expectation you're going to look at
it and go like yeah I need to learn the
skill of managing annoying bosses okay
and if that's the case then you're not
going to be upset about it uh similarly
any anything else if you look at it then
it's not just the event it's your
perception of the event so you have a
something to influence it's not just the
event huh your partner might say
something hurtful on Friday at 4
p.m. that's the event my partner said
something hurtful at Sunday morning you
tell yourself he or she doesn't love me
anymore okay that's your perception of
the event that's not actually the event
the event is something hurtful was said
but your perception of the event is is
your work is your it's your brain adding
color to it and then you compare that to
your expectations right you compared my
boss is annoying to my boss shouldn't be
annoying where did you get that from
right so we blur the happiness equation
we break the happiness equation because
of what I call the six and seven okay
six Grand Illusions and seven blind
spots which are the six Grand Illusions
are basically uh call them
Pathways uh that the modern world
teaches us to navigate the modern world
that our Illusions are not true okay
take for example control everyone knows
that to succeed in the modern world you
have to learn to control certain events
right so you start to believe that the
way to succeed in life is to control
everything but the truth is even if you
go down to the basics of physics that we
never are in control that the the
absolute design of nature itself of the
universe itself is European chaos right
that's the actual design and so if you
try to control it you're bound to be
disappointed a lot of events are going
to miss your expectations okay and yes
I'm not saying don't control anything at
all but start to understand that you're
you're going to be selective because you
have a finite amount of effort and by
the way even if you're selective and you
you try to control everything sometimes
things will fall out of control okay and
that should be your expectation once you
get that right that was one that was my
biggest illusion okay I a mathematician
I'm a software developer I am a
physicist I am an engineer and I'm a
senior executive that doesn't get worse
than that okay I'm like the worst
absolute the worst I used to give my
wonderful wife I swear to you Stephen
don't judge me I used to give her a
spreadsheet that would tell her when to
wash the colors and when to wash the
whites based on our average consumption
as a family to save the environment and
poror Nebel would would actually smile
at me and say sure baby I will use
this of course and ignores the hell out
of me because that's how crazy you can
be when it comes to control now these
are the Illusions if you live your life
through the illusion of control good
luck finding happiness so six Grand
Illusions the illusion of uh of thought
the illusion the illusion of self the
illusion of uh knowledge the illusion of
time control and fear okay now that's
one side and that this disrupts your
your entire view of what to expect from
life because you're expecting life to
behave through a length of a a lens of
an illusion the other side of it is what
I call Seven blind spots okay and the
Seven blind spots are not really defects
in your brain as a matter of fact they
are the very design of your brain okay
your brain is designed to tell you
what's wrong okay it's not designed to
you know if a Tiger shows up right here
now my brain has no you use whatsoever
in telling me Oh my god look how
Majestic that animal is right yeah it's
a beautiful animal but my brain will say
we're going to die okay and we're going
to die is the idea that basically makes
our uh our brain constantly look for
what's wrong blur the events of life huh
you ask a mother and and she will say oh
my daughter's been sick all winter no
she just had two episodes of flu 3 days
each but to the to to the Caring Heart
of a mother that needs to be exaggerated
to the exaggeration is one of the blind
spots your your brain is trying to get
you to take action so it pushes you it
pushes You by exaggerating the event a
little bit so that you jump in and take
action and accordingly the event you're
comparing to you're comparing the wrong
event to the wrong expectation and the
happiness equation falls apart isn't
this cool every single conversation I
have here on the DI of AO at the very
end of it you'll know I asked the guest
to leave a question in the Diary of a
CEO and what we've done is we've turned
every single question written in the
Diary of a CEO into these conversation
cards that you can play at home so
you've got every guest we've ever had
their question their name and on the
back of it if you scan that QR code you
get to watch on your phone the person
who answered that question the next
guest we're finally revealing all of the
questions and the people that answered
the question and we've just released the
updated conversation cards we released
it the first time and it sold out
instantly we released conversation cards
again and they sold out instantly for a
second time we've updated the cards put
all the new questions in and we've
introduced a Twist on the back of the
conversation cards now we've got
different levels of vulnerability so
level one these the more sort of surface
level questions and by the time you get
down to level three the questions become
a little bit more challenging a little
bit more vulnerable and that's really
where connection happens to test the
power of these cards we invited 20 total
strangers to come and have dinner and
the only thing they had to do was answer
a level three question that was put in
front of them in a room full of
strangers and we saw
unbelievable almost magical results
people in tears people forming lifelong
friendships and people unlocking truths
within them that they' been too scared
to confront vulnerability is the door to
connection that is what we've always
done here on this podcast and that's
exactly what these conversation cards do
you can play them with your partner at
home you can play them with your
colleagues at work or you can play them
with your best friend on the weekend the
stories we've heard about these cards
about a grandson playing it with their
grandfather to get to know them pulling
them out in the midst of a divorce with
their wife and saving their marriage as
you've often seen on this podcast
sometimes one question and someone who
is genuinely open to answering it is all
it takes to unlock a truth that will end
up setting you free and that's exactly
why we made these conversation cards and
you can get them right now atth
conversation cards.com I'll put a link
to the conversation cards in the
description below they' sold out twice
instantaneously so if you are interested
in getting hold of some limited edition
conversation cards I really really
recommend acting quickly and let me know
how powerful they were for you and or
for your relationships thank
you do you need a podcast to listen to
next we've discovered that people who
liked this episode also tend to
absolutely love another recent episode
we've done so I've linked that episode
in the description below I know you'll
enjoy
it
[Music]
a